Uh,
well thank you.
It is a great to be with all of you today.
Luke.
Thanks for introducing me.
And also just inviting me here to be with all of you to those of you I've heard
there are people streaming right now.
Um,
that's what I look like,
but I can't give a talk for 45 minutes with myself behind me the whole time.
So apparently when this goes up on Youtube,
they'll integrate it and people there can watch me and not just the slides,
but if you're streaming you're just going to get the slides and my voice,
uh,
from here on out.
So I'm,
so I'm a social neuroscientist.
I have been looking at people's brains mostly using a MRI scanners for about 20
years now,
a little longer than 20 years.
Uh,
and at some point around 10,
12 years ago,
I started getting introduced,
uh,
invited to come speak to different sort of business related groups.
And actually a bunch of the talks were at Oracle early on and other leadership
organizations.
Uh,
and so it got me thinking about,
you know,
what on earth does my work have to say that's relevant to business to thinking
about,
uh,
how the social brain is sort of doing its thing at work.
And so part of what I think about,
um,
is sort of how do we kind of promote wellbeing,
productivity,
happiness,
all these things that you sort of want to see more of at work.
And to do this,
you basically need a good model,
a good theory of what sort of motivates and drives human beings.
Uh,
and so I think that the sort of inherited wisdom we've had for hundreds of
years,
you can't really do much better than Thomas Hobbs who summed it up in a single
sentence.
A man has no other end in all his actions then his private self interest.
Um,
so we get as much good stuff as we can for as little work,
as little pain as possible.
Um,
and if you want to see evidence of this,
um,
one easy way to sort of see this is to go to a game that a economist developed.
I think back in the late eighties,
maybe it was early nineties,
uh,
no,
it was earlier.
It was the 80s called the prisoner's dilemma.
And I'm sure some of you are familiar with the prisoner's dilemma.
I won't describe all the,
the details of it.
The key things you need to know is it typically two people are playing with or
against each other.
They never meet each other and they are never going to meet each other.
They typically play one round of the game.
So there's no concern with reputation.
Uh,
and the key thing about the way you play the game is that your outcomes are
interdependent.
So the way you play affects both your outcomes and the other persons.
And the same is true for them as well.
And so there's two ways you can play the game.
You can play the game,
uh,
selfishly where you try to maximize the amount of money you'll take for and it
is definitively going to come at the expense of less money for the other person.
And the other option is to play in a sort of more communal sort of way where you
try to maximize the amount of money that you and the other person are going to
earn jointly.
But that will definitely come at the expense of you getting less money.
Personally.
These are the two options.
Um,
and in line with economists predictions,
the vast majority of people play this game.
Selfishly.
They go and say,
I'll take the most money for myself.
Thank you very much.
And so games like this,
uh,
give rise to the view of human nature as being something like a homo economic
basis,
something like that where we're basically rationally self interested creatures
where we're fundamentally selfish.
Uh,
we try not to exert too much effort.
We can be reasonably rational in some contexts and we pursue wealth and other
sort of material gains for ourselves.
And that's what's been shown in hundreds and hundreds of iterations of this
game.
Uh,
the prisoner's dilemma,
but there's a version of this game that you are probably not familiar with that
I think it's sort of an interesting contrast.
So actually it's the exact same game.
So in this version of the game,
you have the exact same rules.
Describe to you word for word the same and you play the game exactly the same
way.
But at the start of the game,
when they're introducing the rules,
instead of describing or defining the game one way or another in this particular
version of the game,
they say,
today you're going to be playing the community game.
And then they explain the exact same rules as what is normally taking place in
the prisoner's dilemma.
And when you do this,
the percentage of people who play selfishly drops precipitously and suddenly now
almost everybody,
well three quarters of people suddenly now play communally,
communally and try to sort of do what's best for the group.
And so in addition to suggesting that a human beings are exquisitely sensitive
to context and situational pressures and so on,
what it also may suggest is that we are sort of more than just homo economic us.
We are also homosocial Cialis,
um,
that we may have the sort of intrinsic,
a social concerns.
And that what we're looking for is when we're supposed to demonstrate these
motives.
And when we're supposed to demonstrate those motives.
Okay.
And that we have both of these and we use both.
I'm not trying to suggest we're not selfish creatures.
Uh,
we are,
but we are not only selfish creatures as part of what I'll argue.
So for the time I have with you,
I'm going to try to do three things.
The first thing I'm going to try to do is present to you some of the
neuroscience data that we've collected.
An attempt to sort of prove to you that our ability and our skills at being
social is not just another program we learn like how to play chess or Algebra.
Those are things that we can learn because we have this great prefrontal cortex
that's super flexible and can learn any new sort of rule based kind of thing if
it's useful for us to learn it.
Um,
but instead what I'm going to suggest is,
is that our social operating system is part of the basic components of,
of who we are as mammals.
That all mammals actually share this.
And we have plenty of it as well.
Uh,
if I convince you of that,
hopefully I will,
I'll spend some time then trying to tell you some things about,
uh,
why,
paying more attention to our social nature is really important for thinking
about a happiness,
wellbeing,
and productivity in the workplace.
And then,
uh,
I assume I will have time cause I set a timer for myself to make sure I'd get to
this last piece.
Cause that's the piece I'm actually most excited about.
Uh,
that's about sort of where our work is going and where it's now really directly
relevant to thinking about neuroscience and social neuroscience specifically in
the workplace and how we can sort of use it there,
uh,
in a way that I think really hasn't been used in the past.
But let's start at the beginning trying to convince you that some of the social
aspects of ourself,
um,
are really,
really sort of a basic part of who we are.
So,
um,
let's start with the concept social pain.
Uh,
so we came up with the concept of social pain back in the early two thousands,
and because we came up with it,
we got to define it.
And so our definition,
there's various ones we've used,
but it's the pain associated with actual or potential threats to one social
connections.
And if we want to be sort of extra wordy,
it can be actual threat,
actual or potential threats to one's actual or potential or imagine social
connections.
So it's,
it's sort of a pretty flexible concept.
But when most people see this definition,
uh,
what you're likely to think is,
oh,
I get it.
So people are bothered when they're socially rejected.
So you're using social pain,
but that's just a metaphor.
Social pain is metaphorical language.
It's poetic license.
And so what I want to take a few minutes to do is to think about what it would
take to persuade you that social pain is every bit as much of a real kind of
pain as a when you stub your toe or when you have a headache.
That from the brain's perspective and from an evolutionary perspective,
social pain is very much a real kind of pain.
It just manifests in a slightly different way.
But all physical pains manifest in different ways.
So,
um,
you know,
the first thing that's worth noting is that while this may be a metaphor for
social pain and in English,
we use language like you hurt my feelings and she broke my heart.
So we use the language of physical pain to talk about social pain.
And it turns out it's not just an English.
Uh,
there was a paper published years ago,
not by my group,
uh,
showing that in languages all around the world,
including lots of non romance languages.
The language of social pain is based in the language of physical pain,
at least I assume it is.
I,
every once in a while now when I get up here,
I realize I can't translate most of these,
but I assume the authors who wrote this paper could,
and,
uh,
someone would have made them retract the paper by this point if they were
inaccurate in their translations.
Uh,
so we are neuroimaging folks where neuroscientists,
and so our approach is not to look at how the language is common around the
world,
although I think that's super interesting.
Uh,
but instead we tend to put people in these giant coffin like donuts,
um,
where you hear really loud noises.
It's not a terribly pleasant place to be unless you're me.
I tend to fall asleep and scanners when people put me in.
Um,
it's a little bit like being in the womb or it's terrible.
It's one or the other for most people.
And we bring folks in,
and this was back in 2001,
2002,
we brought folks in and we had them play this silly little ball tossing game
called cyberball.
And in Cyberball,
uh,
you're controlling this hand at the bottom of your,
the subject in our scanner.
You're controlling this hand and you believe you're playing with two other real
people over the Internet who are also laying in scanners.
Right now,
of course,
we are social psychologists,
so we lie to people all the time about what they're doing in the studies.
And after a few minutes the game changes and some of you may now start to be
able to realize how the game changes.
Uh,
the other two people who are really just a code,
they're not people at all.
Uh,
they stopped throwing the ball to the real subject and this goes on for a few
minutes.
Subjects get out of the scanner and they're usually either kind of depressed or
angry,
but they definitely tend to have a significant emotional response to this.
And so what we were interested in is what was happening in the brain while
people were being rejected or a excluded from the game compared to the earlier
period when they had been included.
These are the brain regions associated with the distress of physical pain.
Okay.
So the more bothered you are by any painful experience that you have,
the more activity you're going to see in these two regions.
And when we looked in the brain at what was different between the people's
responses when they were being excluded compared to when they were included,
these were the only two regions of the brain that were more active during
rejection than when folks were included.
Moreover,
when people got out of the scanner,
we asked them to tell us how painful it was to be rejected while they were
playing this very boring game.
And the more they told us they felt that it was a painful experience,
the more these two regions showed increasing responses.
And so this persuades,
I'm a fair number of people that,
um,
social pain is a real kind of pain,
but if it doesn't persuade you,
perhaps the followup study will,
it turns out that if you give people Tylenol,
all these effects go away.
Okay.
So the same painkiller that you take for your headaches actually works.
Some sense for your heartaches,
for your sense of being rejected or excluded.
It works for that as well.
Uh,
important caveat here,
do not try this at home.
Tylenol is super toxic.
500 people a year die from Tylenol overdoses.
Um,
and so while there are clinical trials going on and we did this,
this was done in a very sort of proper appropriate lab based way,
don't do this at home.
Okay.
Um,
there I told you not to.
If you do,
that's on you now.
All right.
Um,
so you know,
we,
we have this I think very basic inborn sensitivity to social rejection that
manifests itself in the form of pain.
And it turns out it's not just humans.
All mammals show this kind of response and they tend to show it in the same
regions of the brain.
So you can look at rats,
you can look at monkeys,
there are other animals that have been looked at as well,
and they tend to show this same response.
We have it because for humans who are born incapable of taking care of
themselves when they're infants,
you need a way to stay connected.
And this makes the infant and the caregiver feel connected and are very
sensitive to distress.
In the other,
especially the caregiver is very sensitive to the social pain,
distress calls given by the infants of pretty much any mammals.
And so the upshot of this is it social pain is one of the things that motivates
us to stay connected,
to stay together.
And that allows us to do all sorts of extraordinary things like build buildings
with air conditioning and roofs and things like that.
That pretty much if you were on your own and weren't feeling any motivation to
connect with other people,
we might never have developed these sorts of things.
Now on the flip side of social pain,
we have social pleasures,
which are a nicer to think about and talk about and so on.
Uh,
and it turns out that the same pretty primitive brain system that we share with
reptiles and most other animals that can walk,
um,
the ventral striatum,
the region shown in fire here.
Um,
this is a region that we've known for years and years responds when people in
the scanner a win money,
uh,
when they get to eat something that's delicious when they look at pictures of
pretty people.
Right?
All those things activate this system,
but it also turns out we've known for a few years now that being liked,
loved,
respected,
or even just feeling understood are all things that activate this same system.
Okay.
Um,
so this is a system that seems to be just as sensitive.
Some evidence suggests it's more sensitive to social rewards.
Then these other kinds of rewards that we sort of tend to think of when we think
of rewards in general.
All right.
It's better to give than to receive.
You've all heard this presumably at some point.
Usually it's associated with someone getting a pretty bad gift,
uh,
around Christmas or Hanukkah.
Um,
does anyone know who first said it's better to give than to receive?
I'll tell you,
your brain,
your brain for a said this because all humans are built with this wired in.
Remember we started with the prisoner's dilemma,
a where you can decide to play selfishly or for the group and if you have any
strong views that you know,
we are rationally self interest going for the money kinds of creatures.
You might imagine that there'd be social norms suggesting that there are times
when we think we're supposed to give money to the group to work communally.
You could say that community condition was just people being sensitive to norms
and being afraid of what the experimenter would think.
But if that's the case,
you would still expect that the brain's reward system to respond most strongly
when people chose to play the game in the way,
that would by definition maximize their own earnings.
But that is not what happens in the prisoner's dilemma and the prisoner's
dilemma.
You get the most activity in the ventral striatum when you play communally.
Okay?
So this is a case does a different kind of social reward.
The first kind I told you about is when people tell you they like love,
respect you.
This kind of social reward is when you do for others.
And it turns out that were built such that doing for others is also a rewarding,
pleasurable experience.
One that we don't always have a very good theory of,
but it definitely is true.
Uh,
Adam Grant who's at the Wharton School in Pennsylvania.
You pen,
um,
he wrote a wonderful book on the benefits of sort of being a giver at work
instead of a taker.
If a,
if you are going to buy one book this year,
well by mine,
uh,
but if you're going to buy two I would highly,
highly recommend his book.
And one of the things he found in this book is that if you go take folks who are
doing relatively menial thankless work,
like working a phone bank trying to raise money for scholarships for the
university where everybody is hanging up and trying to get off the phone with
you and you bring someone in who won one of their scholarships that they're
raising money for,
who then tells some of these phone bank folks about how the work they're doing
actually tangibly benefit someone.
The productivity of these folks goes through the roof.
And when I say it goes to the roof,
I don't mean that day or the next day where you would expect them to be like,
oh that was so great.
That was fun that we heard from that 20 year old telling us what this award
meant for them.
It's a month later that they come back and measure and a month later the
productivity of the folks who got this intervention is dramatically higher.
And this has been replicated several times in different contexts.
So I think it's really legit.
So humans are sensitive to social pain,
social pleasure.
You would think that if these are things that can really move around our
wellbeing,
we might have a system in our brain that helps us navigate the social world so
that we can maximize our social pleasures and minimize the social pains.
Uh,
for some time people thought that it was the sort of basic analytical in the
brain,
which is shown here in Green,
um,
loosely shown here in Green.
These are systems that are involved in math and logical reasoning and accounting
and working memory,
holding things temporarily in mind.
Uh,
but it turns out that there really is a completely separate network that's
involved in our social thinking that doesn't really overlap with the network for
analytical thinking at all.
And we've learned some interesting things about this network.
One of the things we've learned is that these two networks,
the social thinking and analytical thinking networks kind of operate like a
neuro.
See Saul where activity in one going up tends to be associated with activity and
the other going down and vice versa.
They seem to trade off of each other and we can think immediately about how that
might be relevant in the workplace.
Right?
I mean,
I assume Google,
like most companies really prioritizes people being highly analytical.
He skilled many,
many hours of the day.
Uh,
and the goal is to just sort of emphasize that without necessarily detracting
from other sorts of capacities that we might have.
But there's some evidence to suggest that if you're putting the pedal to the
metal on the analytical side,
that may come at a real cost of actually dampening down some of our,
uh,
social skills and our ability to detect certain things socially in others in our
social environment.
Um,
another thing we've learned is sort of a,
a funny result and a,
and I'll show it to you this way.
So let's say I brought you into my scanner.
It's not my scanner,
it's UCLA scanner.
I brought you in and a,
I told you that what you're going to do is lay in the scanner and you're going
to do math for a minute and then you're going to lay there and rest and do
nothing for a minute and then math for a minute and rest and the math is super
easy.
It's like three plus four type math and the rest is nothing.
And this time,
even though I'm a social psychologist,
I'm not lying to you.
This is exactly what you do while you're laying in the scanner.
And so we can go look at these analytical parts of the brain and they will do
just what we would expect them to do.
They'll do something like this.
This is idealized,
but something like this,
when you're doing math,
the analytical parts light up and when you're resting they quiet down because
you don't need them to rest and do nothing while you're laying in the scanner.
Now we can look at the same exact task and what's happening in the social brain,
in the social thinking network.
Well,
what we would expect to see is this,
not much at all,
right?
Cause you don't need your social brain to do math.
In fact,
if you activate your social brain while you're doing math,
it interferes and you don't need your social brain during rest,
right?
So that's what we'd expect to see.
But what you actually see is this.
Okay?
So,
uh,
the social brain comes on incredibly reliably.
Anytime there's a break in the action and it comes on within a few hundred
milliseconds of finishing any sort of cognitive goal directed task.
So there are folks who have done things with depth electrodes.
They put them right in the right positions and they can tell within 300
milliseconds,
it's actually a guy at Stanford nearby that within 300 milliseconds,
the social brain pops back on.
Okay.
Whenever there's a break in the action.
And so we can ask ourselves,
well,
why would that happen?
And while I'm not going to um,
spend lots of time in my lab,
sorry,
in my lecture today going over why that happens.
Um,
what I can tell you is that the summary result from our studies is it to the
extent that you spontaneously activate this network in short periods of
downtime,
in between sort of more significant events in your life.
If the next thing you have to do involves social thinking,
you're better prepared for it.
Okay.
You actually perform better on social tasks where you have to think about what's
going on in the minds of other folks to the extent that this network has
spontaneously activated itself.
And what that suggests is that evolution is essentially made a bet that the best
thing to do with our spare cycles in our brain as we have downtime is to get
ready for thinking socially.
That that is really evolutionarily significant because this is pretty much the
only thing in the brain that has this sort of pattern where every time there's a
break and we can reset,
it resets towards the social domain.
We actually have a lot of data that speaks to that now.
Um,
and so in essence,
what that does for us,
and I think this is really,
really important,
is that when we look out into the world,
we could see all of this just as physical objects in,
you know,
in physical motion,
right?
We could describe it all in terms of physics and mechanics and so on.
But most people,
the vast majority of people when they look at this,
what they see as psychological meaning they see people having thoughts,
feelings,
interactions,
intentions,
um,
and this tendency to turn on this network as we walk into each new experience is
something that sort of prepares us to see the world in a psychological fashion
rather than in sort of a physics based mechanical fashion.
Um,
so that's a very sort of short course on sort of some of the evidence to
suggests that we really do have some basic social features to us and that we are
not purely self interested.
We are not just a homo economic us.
We are that.
But not just that.
Of course I could have skipped those 20 minutes and just showed you the quote
from Albert Einstein where he says,
man owes his strength and the struggle for existence to the fact that he is a
social animal.
Um,
but you know,
then I would have no job being here at all.
I could've just showed you that slide.
So I'm gonna spend a few minutes telling you now about how some of these things
relate to a business directly and then I'm going to turn to what we're doing now
with a different kind of neuroscience.
It's more work relevant and I'm pretty excited to get to that.
Okay.
So in any workplace,
in any business,
you're a off trying to hire folks and it's been a long time now that we've
understood that the goal of hiring folks is to accrue the most talent,
right?
So any HR department is out there trying to sort of find the individuals who are
a plus people.
And the a plus people are the people with the highest Iq is the most training
and experience who went to the best schools and norms about these things change
over time.
But that's roughly speaking,
describing what's happened over the last,
you know,
couple of decades in terms of how we try to acquire people.
And the goal is to make sure then that your company has the most human capital.
Um,
so almost almost like a sort of role playing game where you're trying to get
people with the most sort of intellectual and academic skills for performing the
feeds they will need to do at work.
Some economists looked at this and discovered that if you want to see the
relationship between human capital and the company's bottom line,
the vast majority of that relationship is actually explained by the links
between the individuals in the company.
Um,
and so here what we're talking about is not human capital but social capital,
the extent to which a company makes the boundaries between people and sections
of the company permeable so that they can connect easily with each other.
And what's critical about this is,
you know,
you've got this a plus person down here with some special set of skills and if
they're siloed and they don't feel really connected to other folks,
will that person up there is never going to benefit from their skills when they
could and vice versa.
This person is not going to easily seek them out because they don't have an easy
path to get access to them.
Okay.
So it's important to build this kind of social capital purely for economic
reasons,
uh,
at companies.
Here's another version of have something similar.
So a,
this is sort of a phone bank company I think in Germany and the company humanize
who does sort of the badge testing where it tracks,
you know,
your every movement throughout the day.
They did a study,
uh,
with this company and the way the company was working when they showed up is
that there'd be five or six people in a phone bank that we're in a pod together
and they would get their 15 minute breaks staggered so that they all took their
breaks at different times and humanized came in and said,
hey,
why don't you give them their breaks together?
Because if you give them their breaks together,
they'll actually be more socially connected to one another and actually feel
like they're on a team.
Now,
this seems like a really small difference,
but it turned out that this difference had really significant effects on the
extent to which people at the company felt cohesive with the other people they
worked with,
the productivity they had,
the stress levels they had.
So these simple changes where they're being sensitive to enhancing the social
dynamics of the group had really substantial effects.
And they've done other studies like this as well,
and,
and tend to see something if nobody is focusing on the social aspects of a
company that becomes low hanging fruit because nobody's actually gone after the
low hanging fruit before.
And this is,
I think that sort of thing.
Uh,
we can think about performance feedback,
right?
Everybody gets performance feedback at most companies.
There's a few companies that have done away with it.
It's hard to do away with it.
You want your employees to get feedback,
but nobody likes getting performance feedback.
Uh,
and so for me,
one of the things I always think about when I think about performance feedback
is that for the person giving the feedback,
they're just giving constructive advice for how you can go be more efficient and
effective.
And for the person receiving the feedback,
it's like somebody punching you in the face typically,
unless you're,
you know,
the golden child of,
of whatever company you're working at.
And so we have a way of understanding that,
right?
So we've talked about social pain.
And the idea is,
is that if we think of this as a genuinely painful event for people to be told,
information that may make you feel less valued and worthy at the company that
you're working at,
then it's weird to think that those folks should be able to just go back to work
and be effective.
We wouldn't expect someone to break their leg and then go back to work.
We'd say,
go take that,
get that taken care of and come back to work when you know,
it's all,
you know,
in a cast and,
and feeling better.
There's work that shows that after people have been rejected,
um,
their iqs go down significantly and their performance on standardized tests like
the gres plummet,
right?
68%.
Right?
If you've just been accepted and made to feel good,
39% if you've just been rejected.
Okay.
So after you've just been rejected,
don't go take the Gres.
You will not do well.
Okay?
It's not a good solution.
Eat some ice cream.
Uh,
we can think more directly about happiness and sort of how to promote that.
we know,
of course that,
uh,
two of the major factors that drive happiness are,
money and health.
Uh,
so let's start with health.
so we all know smoking's bad for you,
right?
In California,
almost nobody ever smokes anymore.
But like in most of the world,
lots of people still smoke.
Um,
you can look at the morbidity statistics,
uh,
for your likelihood of essentially dying from different kinds of behaviors,
from like not being physically active,
being obese,
having pneumonia and smoking is like the worst one from,
uh,
behaviors that you can personally engage in.
Okay.
Smoking's really,
really bad.
And that's one of the reasons we spend about a half billion dollars a year in
the United States to stop people from smoking and to get people to stop smoking
once they have started.
But what I haven't shown you here,
which is the most interesting part of the chart,
is that it actually turns out that not cultivating a meaningful social group is
actually more dangerous to your health than smoking 15 cigarettes a day.
Um,
so,
um,
while health is super important for your wellbeing,
turns out that being socially connected is also super important for your
wellbeing.
Um,
we know people value being wealthy.
We know people value material wealth than percentage of people who value it has
gone up and up in the United States.
Um,
and I value it too.
So I'm not really sort of throwing stones at all.
But what I will say is,
is that this seems largely to be a mistake because as wealth rises,
happiness typically doesn't change at all.
And you can cut the data a million different ways unless you're moving people
from genuine poverty too out of poverty,
then every dollar really does change happiness and wellbeing.
But once you hit a certain threshold,
you get very diminishing returns for increasing money.
So what makes people happier?
Well,
the people who report being very happy are the people who spend lots of time
with friends and family.
Have some economists looked at this,
uh,
using money as a sort of comparison point and they said,
okay,
how much does spending an extra hour a week with someone you really like going
to get coffee with them or something like that.
How much does that increase your happiness?
And they put it in terms of money.
They said,
how much money would you have to make extra in a given year in order to get the
same amount of happiness you get from spending an hour a week with a good
friend?
Okay.
Turns out it's a giant amount of money.
You have to make an extra hundred thousand dollars a year to get the same
increase in your happiness and spending an hour with someone you like.
You get to pick the person you're talking about here,
someone you like.
Which of these is more fun working to make an extra hundred grand or spending
time with a friend.
And as we do this,
we have less time to do this,
right?
These are the choices we all make.
We moved cross country for job opportunities and leave our social networks
behind.
Um,
we can think about this within the workplace specifically,
not just having friends in life,
but having friends at work.
It turns out that wall,
people who love the company they work at often say it's because they love the
interesting and challenging work they do there.
Uh,
they also often say their number one reason for loving the company they work at
is the coworkers that they get to work with.
And people who say,
I have a best friend at work.
Um,
people who answer yes to this,
the divisions of companies they work in,
okay.
Tend to have customers who are happier,
they're more productive and uh,
they show greater profit.
Um,
so the upshot of this,
and then I'm going to turn to my last piece is that in the workplace we tend to
think that this is the primary way to incentivize people.
Um,
when you look at all the incentive structures,
they almost always either come down to current or future promised money in one
form or another.
Um,
health plans are just money that are being spent for you and a certain other
material way.
Uh,
and the point is that we have some needs that money are really,
really good at covering.
So if you go to Maslow's hierarchy,
and this is a simplified form with physical,
social and meaning needs a physical needs are pretty well handled with money,
but the other two aren't at all.
And so again,
these become low hanging fruit.
If nobody is incentivizing anyone with these other approaches,
then they become a really effective way for you to sort of make that kind of
difference in whatever group you're working in.
Okay.
So last chunk of what I'm going to talk about is what I think one of the big
parts of the future of social neuroscience is.
And it's going to have a big connection to the workplace and not just be in,
you know,
the ivory tower where,
um,
I tend to work.
Um,
this kind of work involves getting away from giant,
heavy,
uh,
MRI scanners and getting to lightweight portable mobile neuroimaging
technologies like functional near infrared spectroscopy or f nears a Mris depend
on differences in the magnetic properties of oxygenated and deoxygenated
hemoglobin f nine years is kind of the same except it depends on the light
absorption properties that differ between those two types of blood.
Uh,
it's basically just the same thing as the pulse oximeter you wear on your finger
when you go to the doctors,
uh,
except it's all over your brain and it's super po a portable and mobile.
Uh,
so you can sort of put,
you're basically putting a very small computer and a sizable battery in a
backpack would,
you can either wear or put on the table behind the subject.
It doesn't have to actually be on your back,
but it allows you to be flexible in where you do your research and the kind of
research that you can now do that you could never do with an MRI scanner.
And it has downsides as well.
There's no question.
It doesn't have the same spatial resolution as MRI.
And currently it doesn't penetrate very deep into the brain so it gets you the
cortical surface.
But I think in the next five to seven years that's probably going to change a
fair bit as well.
So the first thing we did when we decided to test out this equipment was we
wanted to go replicate something we had done in our lab over and over again.
So there's this paradigm that Emily Falk,
uh,
one of my former graduate students and I developed where we try to persuade
people while they're laying in the scanner and then we,
uh,
ask them later and track them in various ways using risk trackers and other
things,
uh,
to see how much they've actually changed their behavior in line with whatever we
were trying to persuade them of to use sunscreen more to stop smoking,
to get more physical exercise to sleep more.
We do lots of public health types of things like that.
And it turns out that when you see activity in this medial prefrontal region
here that's shown in yellow there,
when that goes up,
when people are seeing the messages,
people tend to then change their behavior and message consistent ways.
We think this has something to do with basically adopting and integrating the
message into your identity because this is a region that is very much associated
with self processes and valuation.
So we think,
but we don't know for sure that that seems to be part of what's going on there.
On the flip side,
when people are resistant to a persuasive message and they're internally counter
arguing saying this is stupid because you see more in the right dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex and you'll see less behavior change over time.
So we did the same thing in our first study with f new years and we basically
found the exact same result.
We were actually pretty shocked that we found this.
We thought maybe we'd get a little bit of something,
but there it is.
So,
um,
this is showing to us at least that we can do something analogous with
[inaudible] is that we could be,
you know,
that we've been doing for years and years with Fmr.
I,
and we had a lot of confidence in,
but [inaudible] has the ability to do so much more than just replicate what
we've been able to do while people were laying on their back in the scanner.
And this often involves,
um,
uh,
an approach called neural synchrony.
Uh,
there's other names for it as well,
but I call it neural synchrony.
And the basic idea is you go to the same spot in two different people's brains
as they're experiencing something.
And you look at how the activity there fluctuates over time.
And to the extent that two people in the same spot in their brains are watching
a video or having a conversation and their fluctuations are fluctuating
together,
that's neural synchrony.
And if they're doing random different things,
there is no synchrony in that case.
And it turns out,
and I'll show you data to back this up in a minute,
that what this really tends to get at is whether two people aren't literally
just being exposed to the same thing,
but are sharing the same experience of it.
They're experiencing it and having the same kind of understanding and
perspective on what's going on.
But first I want to show you what neural synchrony,
uh,
looks like.
Uh,
so these are the results of two people.
these are their brains,
uh,
watching a fighter pilot video.
They didn't watch it together.
They're just time locked to be shown together.
And,
um,
let's see.
To Orient you,
the more sort of red and orange you can see on the color bar over there,
the more activity that's occurring in that part of the brain and the more a sort
of green and blue,
the less activity.
And so I think you'll be able to hear the sound.
We'll just watch this.
It's a 22nd video,
but hopefully you can see the synchrony occur and with your own eyes.
Okay.
Are coming up
backers,
the lead of a banking over the top throngs back cause we just send back.
Okay,
so hopefully you could sort of see it.
If not,
this is sort of each of the two brains at different points in time.
And you can see that the brains are more like each other than they are their own
brain at other points in time.
Now here's the same video shown again this time without sound,
but this time,
this person on the right is internally doing math.
So their eyes are on the video.
If you're looking at them,
you can't tell that they're experiencing it any differently than this person.
But as soon as you see their brains,
it's obvious they are not experiencing the same thing right now.
They are not responding at all the same way to what they're taking in.
And so this is really,
really cool.
At least I think it's really cool that we can tell this without asking people
how distracted,
where you imagine at a,
you know,
a conference room meeting and you're going to ask everyone,
so how distracted?
Where are you during the meeting?
Nobody's going to say I was distracted,
right?
They're all gonna say,
Oh,
I was totally present and man,
I'm having great ideas after that meeting.
Um,
but we all know that we've been that person and there's other people who are
being that person right now.
Some of you have no idea what I'm talking about right now because you're being
that person right now.
And that's fine.
I have no problem with that because if I was in the audience,
I might be that person.
Um,
but I think that's a really interesting thing to be able to detect that I think
in a pretty robust way.
So,
um,
so let me tell you about something that,
that we've done with this where we can show it's really about people sharing
perspective.
Um,
uh,
so we take the equipment,
we put it in our carry on luggage.
Um,
this is Google earth,
so thank you Google for making this,
it,
this impresses people at every other talk I give,
but I assume it would be like,
ah,
that again here.
Um,
so,
uh,
we go halfway around the world to Amman,
Jordan,
and a for the last three summers we've set up pop up mobile neuroscience labs,
ran the first ever social neuroscience studies run anywhere in the country or
the region.
And,
um,
what we were doing in this particular study that I'm going to tell you about is
we were,
we found participants over there who were either a pro choice or pro life with
respect to abortion.
Now,
there is an important debate over there that's pro life pro choice.
It's not the same as our debate.
There's a general belief that abortion is wrong.
Uh,
but there is a debate over whether or not there should be an exception in the
case of rape.
Okay.
So that's what this particular debate is about.
And there's lots of people on both sides.
It's about a 50,
50 split,
which is what we were looking for.
And then,
uh,
we had videos made of um,
local individuals,
uh,
arguing basically for the pro choice side or the pro life side.
So we have videos,
um,
native language videos where people are arguing for these two different sides.
And both groups saw both videos,
wall wearing,
um,
f nears.
So then I'll take you through kind of what we looked at and how this works.
So both groups watch this pro choice video.
Okay?
Uh,
so let's say we pull out one of the people from the pro choice side.
Okay?
So conceptually they're down here.
Now pretend they're not up there anymore.
And so what we can do is we can look at the extent to which this individual is
showing.
I'm a synchronous response with the average of all the pro choice folks up
there.
Okay?
Um,
and you can do this iteratively.
So then you pull out a different subject and put this one back and you do it for
everyone so that you see how each person is correlated with the rest of the
group and the pro choice group.
And when you do this,
what you see is that there's lots of synchrony.
So read on the scale is,
you know,
up at the high end.
And then yellow is,
is also pretty high as well.
So we see lots of synchrony there.
But when we do the same thing,
where we take someone who is pro choice and see how their brain responses
correlate with the folks who are pro life,
it's basically zero correlations,
uh,
throughout the brain,
throughout the frontal cortex where we were looking.
Okay.
So they're seeing the exact same video,
right?
Like the same photons are hitting their eyes,
the same sound waves are hitting their ears,
but they experience it like them and not like them.
And that's what's coming out here.
And we can reverse it a,
so now you pull someone out from the prolife group,
um,
and they'll show synchrony with the prolife group,
but not with the pro choice group,
just for complete sake.
Um,
and so once we started getting results like this,
we started thinking that there were kind of a wide range of applications.
And so,
um,
one of the other people in my department sort of prodded me.
And so we went and started a company so that we could do this in other places
where we wouldn't ordinarily study this in a inside sort of Ucla.
And so the idea here is that as long as we have two different kinds of reference
groups getting out a particular kind of way of experiencing a piece of the
world,
we can now basically figure out what a new case is actually seeing and
experiencing when they're looking at something.
Because we can look at the extent to which they look like more of a match for
one group or another.
And this lets us basically and broadly speaking,
study the science of compatibility.
And it's in a very sort of broad kind of definition.
And so the idea here is if you experience something in similar ways as another
person or group,
um,
Daniel show greater synchrony with that person or group under the proper
stimulus conditions.
So the pro choice person watching approach,
voice,
video,
not watching the Superbowl,
but watching the pro choice video,
then they're experiencing something in the same way or a similar way to those
folks.
Um,
and so then you can see that sort of thing.
So imagine instead of looking at this,
um,
we were trying to figure out,
uh,
who would accompany,
is experiencing burnout right now.
Right?
Some people in this room right now are feeling burned out working.
It's just,
it's a fact of the matter.
There's a decent percentage of people that are feeling burned out and it's a big
problem,
right?
I mean,
people who are burned out leave before they leave.
Their productivity goes way down.
Burnout is contagious.
It's something that like anyone running a company or somewhere up in management
really,
really wants to avoid,
but you can't go to your employees and say,
tell me on a scale from one to 10,
how burned out are you feeling?
Um,
because people are typically not going to tell you.
That's not one of those things we reveal in interviews and,
and performance reviews and things like that.
But we can do the same kind of thing we did with the pro choice pro life.
Okay.
Uh,
but now instead of looking at pro choice pro life,
we're looking at videos of CEOs and executives talking about feeling really
engaged or feeling burned out.
Okay.
And then we have people that have already told us that they are feeling engaged,
are burned out,
and we can see how they respond when they watched these videos and look at how
that relates to individuals in this way.
So to get it this,
it's hard to get a bunch of executives and CEOs in a room.
They don't like to all show up at the same time.
So we went to them,
um,
a few months ago we went to this event summit La,
it's a,
an ideas fast for basically really wealthy CEOs and executives.
Um,
I could never afford to go to this event unless I was invited,
which I was thankfully.
Uh,
and so once we were there,
people say yes to everything.
And so we were super excited that a bunch of CEOs and executives were happy to
come in and get their brain scan together.
Um,
this is literally the first time four people have ever been scanned while having
a conversation.
Like that's never happened in any form.
Um,
so we thought that was pretty cool in and of itself and they did interesting
things while they were having conversations.
I'm not going to tell you about that data today.
But another thing they did is at one point there's a TV here.
They all turned and looked at the TV and they watched videos like these.
So they saw some people talking about how engaged and excited they are at work.
Like this guy.
What's really exciting to me personally is the the ability to make an impact for
millions if not billions of people,
you know,
having a commercially successful product that is driven by technology but
ultimately making the human experience better.
We get a lot of messages saying thank you ivy,
which is our hotel concierges that we created by texting you.
I was able to get it in two minutes at my door and it really you,
you're a lifesaver,
right?
So you've got people like that and then you've also gotten it,
to be fair,
he talked about the both the good and bad side and this next guy talked about
the good and bad side.
So it's not like this next guy is like super burned out and we have to everyone
to talk about both aspects of their job at different times.
This is someone talking about feeling stressed out about being a CEO.
Um,
you know,
it's a very stressful environment.
It's sort of high risk,
high reward.
You've got a lot riding on pulling it off and that falls on the CEO and on
management.
And you've got,
you know,
your investors are relying on you.
You've got your employees who um,
uh,
you know,
that's their job and they're feeding their families and their living.
And so,
you know,
a lot of times it gets very close to the flame.
It's
okay.
So imagine that you're either feeling super jazzed about the work you're doing,
you're right where you should be or you're feeling burned out.
You're probably going to experience these two kinds of videos differently based
on what's going on with you in your life right now.
And so that's what we wanted to look at.
So,
um,
basically everything I'm going to show you is from this same medial prefrontal
spot that I've shown you in some of the previous studies before.
It seems to be associated with identity and sort of integrating things.
And I'm identifying with something that you're taking in.
And so what we see is that when people are watching the sort of,
what do you love about what you do,
types of videos,
what we see is that the sort of engaged CEOs and executives,
um,
they show a fair amount of synchrony with one another in,
in that condition.
But the folks who are feeling burned out don't really show any synchrony when
they're watching these folks talk about how excited and engaged they are.
When you see the folks talking about being stressed and burned out.
Now instead you see the burned out.
Um,
folks who are sort of stressed and,
and feeling the pressure,
these folks are showing more synchrony with one another.
Um,
then the executives who are engaged in thriving and so on.
So putting that together,
uh,
what you essentially see is that the engage CEOs show I'm a lot more synchrony
for the engaged videos and the folks who are feeling more burned out,
show more synchrony with the,
the burnout videos,
the stress videos.
Right.
And we were actually using very simple sort of machine learning classification,
able to classify about 85% of the folks who were feeling burned out as being
burned out based on their brain data.
Uh,
and so,
you know,
I think that's sort of a promising thing because,
doing this,
you don't actually have to go ask folks.
We knew because we were running that kind of study.
But in the future it could be used in an application where you don't know in
advance.
Um,
who's feeling one way or the other?
I'll just mention a couple of the other applications of this before I stop.
Um,
Dana Landis is in here,
right?
Is that right?
Now?
Okay.
So Dana Landis is at Google,
but she's also,
um,
on our advisory board.
And so we've talked with her about sort of working towards,
um,
solutions for the diversity pipeline.
I know you guys have it in tech.
We have it in academia.
It's a,
a genuine,
real issue that's really,
really hard to solve.
And one of the things that we've sort of talked about is that you can go to
folks who aren't necessarily,
uh,
you know,
necessarily getting exposed to the best,
uh,
training and they're not getting it in an environment saying an inner school,
um,
uh,
inner city school environment,
elementary school,
middle school and so on where not only are you not getting it,
but there's not a lot of emphasis in the family or among friends to really
cultivate an attitude towards what I should spend my time and energy on is
learning how to do Algebra or something like that.
It's just not necessarily especially valued for understandable reasons in that
context.
But if you can go in and actually look at who shows brain responses when they
look at certain mathematical or other types of stem concepts that even look a
bit more like folks who have excelled in that region,
could you identify aptitude and folks who aren't going to show it on traditional
tests?
And there's some reasons to think that you actually can do this as this is
something where if you can identify those folks when they're young,
you could bring them over summers to sort of summer institutes where they,
some of the kinds of exposure and a sort of norm setting that would lead people
to get to a place like Google where they probably wouldn't otherwise.
And probably the idea that I'm most excited about is that if we can get data
from the other work we're doing on what sort of thriving,
engaged brains look like in a bunch of different careers.
Okay,
then you could develop what we call the neural guidance counselor,
where you could take a 17 year old who has no idea what to do with their life.
And if you go to a regular guidance counselor,
you're not going to get any better idea of what to do with your life.
I don't know that anyone's ever had a good experience with a guidance counselor.
They're either neutral or creepy.
Like those are like the two options.
Um,
but what if you could basically go find out,
okay,
well these are the things where you as a 17 year old,
you look at certain things in a way that's at least a bit similar to people in
certain professions who are both productive,
successful and really happy doing that job.
Um,
there's lots of other things to think about in terms of,
uh,
team construction.
So we had these groups at summit and they were having conversations with each
other and there's lots of interesting dynamics.
Like we varied,
uh,
the gender composition of the groups across the sessions and we don't have that
data analyzed yet,
but we're really,
really interested to see how synchrony profiles change when it's zero women,
one women to women through women's.
So on.
Right.
That's going to be really interesting.
Also,
some of these people are the same people who told us they were feeling burned
out.
It turns out the people who are feeling burned out also reported being the least
interested and engaged in what anyone else had to say when they were at the
sessions.
Right?
So here's a way in which the sort of burnout feature is actually having a
genuine impact on the way they interact with others.
And when the folks who are feeling burned out was asked,
who was the most interesting,
engaging person at the table,
they were much more likely than anyone else to say me.
Okay.
Most other people pointed to someone else at the table,
I mean in writing and said,
oh,
that person was really interesting.
But the folks who are feeling burned out,
they said,
I guess I was the only interesting person at the table.
Um,
last thing is that,
um,
there's the obvious I think application that this actually directly applies to
regular old matchmaking.
Um,
and uh,
we've thought about this a fair bit,
but we think that this gets at a kind of compatibility where,
you know,
when you,
uh,
you know,
use Tinder or whatever else,
there's no measurement of compatibility on match.com or e harmony who even used
to pretend that they did compatibility.
It turns out it wasn't.
There's interesting stories about that that I won't go into,
but you can actually measure compatibility in a,
in a meaningful sort of way.
You want to find people,
like the person that you want to find and spend your life with is probably going
to be someone that actually in meaningful ways sees the world similarly to the
way you see it.
Not visually,
but conceptually.
And this is a way to get at that.
And there is data that suggests that this,
in fact,
Ken predict who will become friends.
Uh,
and there's no reason to think it couldn't predict who would become friends that
are more than friends if you take into account attraction and things like that.
Um,
so I think that's sort of a really interesting feature of this as well.
So,
uh,
I know that at this point,
um,
I have gone long and so I will stop there and,
uh,
say thank you and I'm happy to take any questions if there are any.
Thank you.
Yup.
So is there any sense of what types of companies increased social interactions?
Like what are the variables that are relevant?
Like one of the ones that we talk about often as the open workspace environment.
There's like a big study that came out about a recently.
Yeah.
Are there other things like that that kind of are useful when it comes to and
Chris and sorta like social interaction in a good way?
Yeah,
sure.
So,
um,
I,
and I've given talks for companies about sort of creating agile workspaces
where,
you know,
nobody has their own desk or anything like that.
It kind of seems like a disaster,
um,
to do that for lots of reasons.
I think anyone who works in one of those spaces knows you get a room full of
people wearing headphones,
but people also feel a bit better if they have some space ownership.
It turns out a lot of the motivation for making those kinds of spaces is that
the company can lease a lot less space because when you're not there,
somebody else can sit at the same desk.
Right?
Um,
now there is evidence that suggests that I'm putting people in proximity to each
other is really important.
So humanize who did the thing with the water cooler or 15 minute breaks and so
on.
One of the other studies they did is they looked at,
I think this was with Deutsche Bank,
um,
were some bank,
I may not be Deutsche Bank,
I may just have that on the brain lately.
Um,
but they had different banks were in some of the banks,
everyone who worked in a certain division was on the same floor.
And in some companies they were just on slightly different floors,
like one floor apart with a stairwell internal to it connecting them.
And there were dramatic differences.
They managed to convince them to switch one of these,
uh,
to one of these and the productivity went way up.
And that seems to be due to the fact that now you've created a better case for
social permeability so that people can connect more easily and so on.
I think the other thing is,
is that we tend to just not think about it very much and so it's easy to do.
I run a lab,
it's easy for me to forget that.
Um,
you know,
in some sense,
part of my job is,
uh,
providing for and creating the right social atmosphere.
We think,
well,
I provide my students with resources and I try to give them sort of good advice
and wisdom and so on.
Um,
but this is also where they're living part of their social life for several
years.
I mean,
we spent so many hours at work,
um,
that that has to sort of have some of the same features that we look for outside
of work.
And I think that companies sort of think,
well,
I don't want to spend extra money on those things,
but it turns out you're not because it reduces burnout at reducing.
It's a good play for the company,
but it's also really good for the people who work there.
Sure.
I new nears.
Yeah.
So I think,
uh,
I'm just thinking whether it could be useful for personal emotion note to
element or,
I mean,
how much does it cost it?
Have you thought about that?
Sure.
So,
um,
they're,
I mean,
okay,
so there's a couple of answers to this.
One is there's a lot of fly by night equipment out on the market right now and
the vast majority of it is junk.
Um,
so there's like a bunch of portable EEG things where you get a single lead that
doesn't actually connect the right way to the scalp,
like you're supposed to use certain kinds of leads that those don't because
they're messy and expensive.
Um,
and so there's a lot of stuff out there that's junk that people are using that
I'm sure there's some signal but it's also a signal swamped by noise.
Um,
f nears like anything has some signal,
some noise.
So you know,
but I think the signal I've been convinced at the signal is meaningful at this
point,
although we're still sort of testing those things in terms of using them for
sort of personal use.
Um,
I do think that that is a plausible longer sort of time horizons scenario.
Right now.
They are a bit clunky to set up.
You need a technician there to set it up.
I don't know that you could effectively set up your own right now.
Um,
but we are working with hardware companies about uh,
engineering plans for how to make this more consumer friendly at some point down
the road.
So I think maybe in five years we might be looking at that if you wanted to buy
one for yourself.
The sort of the lowest end one that I would think is really worth using is
probably about a hundred grand.
Um,
there's toy ones that you can get for 50,
but they are,
I really do think they are toys and very,
very limited in what they can do.
A hundred grand would basically get you with pretty good signal,
your prefrontal cortex and then it doubles and triples and so on from there.
And then in terms of the other part of the question,
could you use it for post personal emotional development?
It would take something really rigorous,
I think set up by some kind of company to make that work.
I don't think you could just sort of sit there and stare at your signal and say,
okay,
I'm going to work these parts of my brain and,
and have that be terribly meaningful.
Yeah.
So,
so we actually a right now are starting a collaboration with a clinical
psychologist at Ucla,
Michelle crass,
where we're going to have both the therapist and the client where f nears during
like they do like 12 sessions,
12 weeks of sessions.
And so they're going to do it in week one,
I think week three,
six,
nine and 12.
Um,
and so we're very interested in how the dynamics both within the individuals and
across the individuals change over time and how that predicts a sort of who
feels like they've gotten the most out of it and also who sticks with it because
most people actually drop out before they get to what therapists say should be
the natural stopping point I met.
Um,
I also have a question about,
um,
f years.
Um,
so the first thing that pops in my head when you mentioned that it could be used
to measure burnout when people don't actually accurately report it as something
like Black Mirror.
Um,
and I was saying it was just one,
not to bias you,
but I was wondering,
um,
what do you see as like a practically a way to get people to,
to,
to get their burnout measured or something similar like that and what are the
ethical implications of being able to do that?
Right.
Um,
so that's a good question.
Uh,
we,
we get the burnout,
the,
the black mirror comment very regularly.
We actually at some point thought about like naming the company something that
would be an inside joke about black mirror,
like something from one of the episodes just to be like really like,
Yep,
that's,
that's where you know,
we live.
Um,
and I think that really depends on sort of how a company wants to sort of pitch
what they're doing to their employees.
So,
you know,
if finding out folks are burned out is then used in some threatening way,
then you know,
that's not really good for anyone.
But if it's used in a way to sort of direct more resources and to sort of help
folks who are vulnerable for leaving the company or who might benefit from
certain types of interventions,
um,
then that's something that I think is probably more positive.
But I totally agree that there's some uses of what we're doing.
Like the neural guidance counselor thing,
that's a pure benefit for anyone who goes and does it.
Like if you're 17 and you go and do this,
you get told like you're a 90% match with this and a 30% match with that and do
without what you want.
But you might not have known these things.
A lot of us grew up thinking,
well,
I should do what my parents did or something like that.
Are we getting to a random internship after college?
And suddenly that's our career 20 years later.
Um,
this is a way to sort of try out things that you could never go try out on your
own.
So I think that there's sort of a range of different applications and some of
them,
um,
I think that folks who want to use this,
we'll have to think about,
well,
what are the benefits that a person gets?
And there are lots of potential benefits so you could get information yourself
that relates not necessarily just to burn out if you're feeling burned out,
you probably know that.
But there's a lot of other things about the extent to which you serve shows
certain kinds of skills and aptitudes and so on.
Uh,
people love things like the Myers Briggs,
even though it's complete junk,
right?
It doesn't actually tell you anything meaningfully,
any,
you know,
psychometrician we'll say don't ever,
ever use that.
Um,
but people are really,
really interested because they want to sort of get this kind of standardized
feedback.
And I think that is one of the things that this could be used to do.
We haven't done that specifically,
but I think it could be used in,
in some of those domains.
And it could be used,
um,
to see if you sort of qualify to get certain kinds of trainings or promotions or
whatever.
So you could have your brain scan.
So imagine the neural guidance counselor and it says you're a great match for
this,
but you don't test well and things like that.
Right?
This could be common part of partial substitute where you say,
well,
I don't test well,
but I'll probably do the actual thing.
Well,
because my brain looks like the people who do the actual thing.
that's an interesting possibility.
And on behalf of Google,
I would like to thank Matt and would also like to say Ucla is very lucky to have
you and we are very lucky to have you for this hour.
Thank you,
Luke.
Thank you so much.
Everyone.